en el vídeo pasado habíamos definido el
error cuadrática entre cierta línea de
la mx b y cada uno de estos puntos bueno
el conjunto de estos puntos como esta
expresión de aquí lo que procede ahorita
es manipular algebraica mente esta
expresión y dejarla lista para meterla
al horno o sea la parte de cálculo una
vez hecho esto vamos a poder encontrar
m&b con unas derivadas parciales para
que se minimice el error cuadrática
entonces ahorita lo que va a pasar es
que vamos a hacer un montón de álgebra
para que esta parte no sea tan tediosa
voy a intentar poner colorcito
correctamente déjame reescribir esto
vamos a empezar reescribiendo esto pues
expandiendo los cuadrados entonces vamos
a empezar con el primer término lleva 1
- mx1 más b al cuadrado y eso de ahí
elevándolo al cuadrado va a ser igual a
este término es igual a en azul ayer 1
al cuadrado
- dos veces el primero por el segundo o
sea menos dos veces ya 1 x mx1b
finalmente hay que sumar el segundo al
cuadrado es decir mas mx1b al cuadrado
lo único que hice fue elevar este
binomio al cuadrado que podemos pensarlo
como a menos b al cuadrado y entonces
queda al cuadrado menos 2 sabe más b al
cuadrado esto es simplemente lo que hice
ahora vamos a hacer eso para cada
término es casi la misma idea aquí
verdad simplemente cambian los términos
en xy le voy a escribir aquí abajo para
que podamos sumar después más fácilmente
entonces el segundo nos queda de 2
elevado al cuadrado menos 2 veces de 2 x
mx2 más ve más mx2 más b elevado al
cuadrado es exactamente lo mismo que
arriba solo que ahora tenemos en vez de
x 1 ig1 pues x 2 y de 2 vamos a seguir
haciendo esto con cada uno de los
sumandos
entonces vamos a seguir así para el x 3
de 3 para el x 4 4 y así hasta que
lleguemos al último término al enésimo
nos queda más que al cuadrado y luego
tenemos que restar dos veces n x mx n b
y luego hay que sumar m por equis n más
b elevado al cuadrado
muy bien ahora la siguiente cosa que
quiero hacer es expandir cada uno de
estos términos quiero hacer las
multiplicaciones y los cuadrados vamos a
bajar aquí entonces toda esta expresión
la voy a reescribir y nos va a quedar
igual a pues a ver esto de que es el
error cuadrática y lo primero que nos
queda es que 1 al cuadrado y luego voy a
distribuir este menos 2 1
entonces nos quedaría nos quedaría menos
2 veces
1 mx1 simplemente es eso por eso menos
21 x b
con eso desarrollamos el segundo sumando
vamos al tercero expandiendo el binomio
al cuadrado nos queda m cuadrada por x 1
al cuadrado más 2 veces
mx1 por b dos veces el primero por el
segundo más cuadrado el segundo al
cuadrado lo único que hice fue pensarlo
como amarre al cuadrado y hacer cuadrada
más dos sabe más b cuadrada vamos a
hacer esto para cada uno de los términos
oa lo mejor debería decir para cada
color
pasemos al segundo renglón va a ser
exactamente lo mismo pero en vez de 12 y
en vez de x1 es x2 nos quedan dos
elevado al cuadrado menos dos veces de
dos x mx2 menos dos veces de 2 x b más m
cuadrada por x2 al cuadrado más dos
veces mx2b más b al cuadrado muy bien
vamos a seguir haciendo esto para cada
uno de los términos hasta el final
entonces puntos suspensivos y el último
nos quedaría más esto de acá entonces
nos quedaría más g n al cuadrado menos 2
veces
n
sí verdad menos dos veces gene por mx n
de hecho ni siquiera hay que pensar solo
hay que cambiar los subíndices de 2 a n
va o sea no hay que desarrollar todo
otra vez entonces siguiendo así nos
quedaría menos dos veces llene por ve
más m al cuadrado por equis n al
cuadrado más dos veces x n por b más b
al cuadrado excelente entonces una vez
más esto de aquí sigue siendo el error
cuadrática no hay que olvidarnos que
esto viene del error cuadra tico entre
la línea y los puntos ahora vamos a ver
si podemos pues juntar los términos
similares para hacer esto lo que voy a
hacer es pues intentar sumar por columna
vale entonces si sumo todos los términos
que están en la primera columna nos voy
a marcar con amarillo toda esta columna
de aquí que me quedaría pues nos
quedaría ya 1 al cuadrado más de 2 al
cuadrado más
pues todo está más n al cuadrado va esto
de aquí es la primera columna entonces
voy a tener eso de ahí y luego voy a
tener pues estas expresiones en la
segunda columna de hecho pues fíjate
casi todos estos o más y en todos estos
tienen menos 12 m en cada uno de los
elementos aparecen menos 2 cm entonces
lo vamos a factorizar entonces vamos a
obtener la vez que voy a poner
paréntesis por aquí ahora si lo que nos
quedaría es menos 2 m menos 12 m y luego
hay que multiplicar por pues cada uno de
estos términos para entonces que nos
quedaría son los que déjame poner todo
con colores correctamente para que quede
mucho más claro
entonces vamos a borrar hasta acá
entonces simplemente estamos haciendo
manipulaciones algebraicas nos queda 1
al cuadrado más set 2 al cuadrado más y
así hasta allí n al cuadrado esa es la
primera columna le ponemos paréntesis y
a eso vamos a sumarle este término común
que es menos 12 m osea lo vamos a
factorizar
vamos a este factor no en vez de más es
menos verdad déjame borrarlo voy a
ponerle menos 2 m x y que nos va
quedando pues la suma de productos
verdad nos queda de 1 x 1
no voy a poner mejor como x 1 y uno va
ese es éste término de aquí luego hay
que sumar x 2 vamos a ponerlo con el
color rojo que le corresponde más x 2 y
2 más y luego vamos a seguir sumando y
sumando así hasta x nn x 1 o sea seguir
sumando y sumando sumando y sumando
hasta que llegamos hasta x n&n
corresponde a este término de aquí muy
bien esto de aquí es la segunda columna
entonces déjame marcarlo con otro color
esta segunda columna que estoy marcando
con rosa mexicano es lo mismo que esté
sumando que escribí en la expresión de
abajo vamos a la tercera columna saber
en la tercera columna una vez más
podemos factorizar
pues un -2 ve verdad todos estos tienen
un -2 ve nos queda menos 2 b y luego eso
hay que multiplicarlo por pues que nos
va quedando nos queda 1 luego hay que
sumar 12 lo pongo en rojo más dos más y
así sucesivamente hasta que llegamos a n
entonces voy a ponerle más
n muy bien entonces pues lo marcamos con
otro color
esto que estoy marcando en verde la
tercera columna cuando la sumamos nos
queda el tercer sumando que estoy
subrayando aquí vamos a seguir con esto
en el siguiente vídeo lo que vamos a
hacer es simplificar esto un poquito
ahorita tal vez se me acabe el tiempo
ahorita vamos a acabar con estas sumas
vamos con la cuarta columna misma ideal
aquí tenemos una m cuadrada que podemos
factorizar nos queda m al cuadrado por
equis uno al cuadrado más x2 al cuadrado
más y así espérame tantito aquí se me
olvidó otra vez a ver colores
concentración ok entonces nos queda x 1
al cuadrado más x 2 al cuadrado más
patata hasta que llegamos a más x n al
cuadrado
muy bien a ver acá arriba el yen y al
cuadrado era rosa y elche 2 al cuadrado
era rojo
creo que sí ya arregle todo lo de los
colores muy bien entonces hasta ahorita
hemos llegado hasta la cuarta columna y
esta cuarta columna de aquí es este
último término que sumamos que sumamos
me faltaba aún más ahora pasemos a la
quinta columna ya casi terminamos a ver
aquí tenemos un 12 mb entonces vamos a
sumarle 2 mb x y ahora nos va quedando x
1 y a eso tenemos que sumarle x 2 lo
pongo con rojo x2 ahora no se me olvido
bueno hay que llegar hasta aquí cn muy
bien entonces sumamos así hasta x n
excelente con esto ya logramos hacer la
penúltima columna esto que estoy
encasillando es igual al último sumando
que acabamos de poner muy bien ya nada
más falta el último jalón en la última
columna tenemos un montón de hebe
cuadradas cuantas b cuadradas tenemos a
pues tenemos una por renglón y como los
renglones están numerados desde uno
hasta n entonces tenemos sumadas n b
cuadradas que es lo mismo que en x b
cuadrada la última columna suma n b
cuadrada y entonces nos queda más n por
b cuadrada muy bien ahorita no se ve muy
prometedor esto verdad de hecho se ve
bastante complicada esta expresión esto
sigue siendo el error cuadrática el
error cuadrática de la línea y de los
puntos ahora insisto hasta ahorita no se
ve muy prometedor pero en el siguiente
vídeo nos vamos a enfocar en
simplificarlo para finalmente poder
pasar a la parte de cálculo hasta la
próxima